قالت الامم المتحده ان دمشق مازالت تحتفظ
باليات عسكريه في المدن انتهاك واضح لخطه
عن ان ياتي ذلك مع استمرار الاحتجاجات ضد
النظام السوري خاصه في دمشق
نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لنناقشه في عنوانين
رئيسيين ما هي عوامل نجاح عمل فريق
المراقبين الدوليين
ومن يتعين عليه توفيرها ومع استمرار
الاحتجاجات اليوميه خاصه في دمشق مع مع
النظام
وقف اطلاق النار هش وغير مستقر هذا ما
قاله رئيس فريق المراقبين الدوليين في
دمشق روبرت مود واضاف انه حتى عند وصول
فريق المراقبين بالكامل والبالغ عددها
ثلاثمائه شخص فلن نكون قادرين على الوجود
في كل انحاء سوريا طوال الوقت وبوضع هذه
التصريحات الى جانب تصريحات مساعد الامين
العام للامم المتحده لشؤون عمليات السلام
التي قال فيها ان دمشق لم تسحب كامل
الياتها العسكريه من المدن فان خطه كوفي
عنان تتعرض للتهديد حقيقي على الارض
وقف اطلاق النار في سوريا
خلاصه توصل اليها مراقبو الامم المتحده
بعد اقل من شهر على بدء مهمتهم
نحن نرى افعال تؤكد ان وقف اطلاق النار
عشر غير مستقر وحتى عندما يكتمل عددنا لن
نكون قادرين على الوجود في كل انحاء سوريا
في ذات الوقت لابد من حل سياسي لتضافر
جهود الحكومه والمعارضه و عواصم العالم
والامم المتحده وقد حمل مساعد الامين
العام للامم المتحده للشؤون عمليات السلام
انجوس ومسؤوليه خروقات لوقف اطلاق النار
لكل من الحكومه والمعارضه واكد ان النظام
السوري لم يسحب الاليات العسكريه من
المراكز السكنيه ويقول انها ليست مزوده
بالذخائر واوضح ان الحكومه السوريه رفضت
منح تاشيرات للمراقبين ينتمون الى مجموعه
دول اصدقاء سوريا التي تشمل اكثر من ستين
بلدا وقال ان الحكومه السوريه رفضت السماح
باستخدام الطائرات المروحيه التي تحمل علم
الامم المتحده توالي وصول المراقبين
الدوليين الى سوريا من دول مختلفه للتحقق
من وقف اطلاق النار بينما يتجه البعض من
ناشطي الثوره الى مقاطعه زياراتهم التي
يصفونها بانها اسمه بتسجيل حضور بجولات
المراقبين حسب الناشطين تقتصر على دقائق
قليله حيث لا يترجلون في اغلب الاحيان من
سياراتهم وعقب مبادرتهم تعود قوات النظام
لاطلاق النار على المتظاهرين واعتقال او
تصفيه من ادلى بشهادته ويتخذ مراقبون
الامم المتحده من العاصمه دمشق مقرا رئيسا
لهم حيث يستعينون لوجيستيا بمقررات وكاله
غوث وتشغيل اللاجئين اونروا وقد شملت
جولتهم التفقديه كلا من دمشق وريفها ودرعا
وحماه وحمص وادلب وحلب وابقوا على مراقبين
ثابتين في بعض المناطق وبقيت محافظه دير
الزور حتى الان خارج خريطه جولات
المراقبين رغم تعرض مدن وبلدات فيها للقصف
تم وحسن والكوريه والبحيره حسب الناشطين
وكذلك ايضا لم تطلق اقدام اصحاب القبعات
الزرقاء محافظه الحسكه ذات الكثافه
الكرديه في هذه الاثناء يواصل النظام
السوري التحضير لاجراء انتخابات مجلس
الشعب الاسبوع المقبل في حين صعد ناشط
الثوره انشطتهم السلميه داخل العاصمه دمشق
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من
نيويورك بيرلو الصحفي في الامم المتحده
ومن العاصمه السوريه دمشق عبر الهاتف
الاعلامي الشريف هذا نبدا من نيويورك
والسيد لو ونسال على ضوء تصريحات اه اه
روبرت مود وحتى تصريحات اه
اه كيف يمكن تقييم اداء بعثه المراقبين في
سوريا الى حد الان
صعوبه في مكان
ان نقول انهم لانهم لم يمضي وقتا طويلا
بالوقت القصير فقط الامم المتحده تقول ان
كان لوجودهم بعض التاثير على سبيل المثال
في مدينه حمص حيث وصل مراقب ان
وتراجع مستوى العنف من ثم يحافظون بالقول
انه حتى بوجود فقط اثنين من المراقبين
بانهم موجودون كرمز للامم
المتحده ولكن على ايه حال ال هدنه وقف
اطلاق النار على ما يبدو انه ليس وقف
اطلاق نار ولا هدنه طالما ان هناك اطلاق
نار من الجانبين ومازالت الاسلحه الثقيله
موجوده على الارض والامم المتحده تقول ذلك
يوميا والامم المتحده كوفي عنان الطالب
سوريا بسحب القوات كما وعدت السلطات
السوريه لكن لم تفعل اذا حتى الان الوضع
لا يمكن ان يوصف بهدنه رغم ان الناس يصفون
كذلك رغم ان الناس يقفون الوضع بالهدنه
يعتقد السيد بانه لا هدنه ولا ولا وقف
لاطلاق النار
اضافه الى ذلك الاتهامات من الامم المتحده
للنظام السوري بعدم سحب الاليات من اه
المدن كيف يمكن الرد على كل ذلك
اه
مساء الخير استاذه
حقيقه سوريا التزمت لما اتفقت عليه مع
السيد وفي موضوع السحب الاليات الثقيله
هناك اتفاق بين سوريا وبين الوقت الذي
السنه السيد في هذا الوقت تحدثت مع
الاستاذ الرئيس الجمهوري رئيس الوزراء
وزير الخارجيه السيد المقداد عن ان هناك
بعض الاليات
تبقى على الارض المدرعات بقيه الاليات فقط
لكن هذا ليس يتضمن على الاطلاق في مبادره
من الذي قرر على ترك هذه الاليات والنظام
السوري قال لانه تركها وهي غير مزوده اه
حتى ان البعض حكم على هذه التصريحات وصفها
الغير المنطقه لما تبقى ان لا تكون فيها
خيره
سيدتي الكريمه المعقده
بالاتفاق الذي وقعته سوريا
سوريا ان تبقى بعض الاليات حاملات الجنود
بعض الاسلحه الخفيفه لكن سوريا في مجمل
الامور يجب ان يفهم الجميع امرا واحدا ان
توزيع القوات في سوريا
فيما هو توزيع حول المدن اي بمعنى الذي
رياض في سوريا متصله مع المدن وبالتالي
فانه اذا
واحد كيلو متر عن المحاكم الدراسه
اليات ثقيله ودبابات هذا ليس وليس العدل
هذا اه وطبيعه سوريا العراقيه وقد
قد يرى احد المراقبين ان هناك جدا على راس
طبيعي لان اه سوريا
سوريا
تقول ان الامور هو الجغرافيه الجغرافيه
البحث
معارضه من داخل سوريا ايضا من انضم الينا
الان عبر عضو مجلس الثوره محمد السيد محمد
كما ذكرها السيد شريف شحاده اسبابها الى
اي مدى ممكن ان تقنع كم وندعم ملاحظاتكم
انتم على الارض خصوص اداء المراقبين وعدم
سحب الاليات وكل ذلك
نحن لم نرى الدبابات الا بعد الثوره
السوريه حينما كانت تقتحم اه قبل هو انا
من الريف الدمشقي لم نقل الدبابات وليست
صحيح ان توزع اه التوزع الجغرافي القوات
السوريه اه يكون هناك مدرعات او غيرها
باريس صحيح ان نرى الدبابات والمدرعات قبل
الثوره السوريه لم نراها الا عندما كانت
تقصف المدن حقيقه اللجنه المراقبين
الدوليين التي دخلت الى سوريا كان من
فائده الجيش السوري الحر استراحتها قوات
الجيش السوريه المدرعات والتطورات وشبيحه
ايضا وزاره تدمير واحراق كبير من ال من من
من المدن القديمه وحرستا والمزارع في
حمايه والفنيه والبارحه وهو قصفت مدينه
داريا استشهد ايضا خمسين شخصا على الاقل
من طناش اربعه الى العام بالاضافه لسقوط
مئات الجرحى والاف المعتقلين الذين لهم
بشكل هذا طبعا في حضور المراقبين نعمل
حضور المراقبين السيد محمد لكن ماهي
ملاحظاتكم على اداء هؤلاء المراقبين هل
تغير شيء في حياه السوريين بتواجدهم على
قلتهم اه وهم اه كما ذكر المسؤولون في
الامم المتحده
من هم من يتواجد بصفه دائمه في بعض المدن
ال ان يحسن الوضع
لا لا لم يحسن الوضع ابدا بالعكس نحن
شاهدنا الحمله على الريف الدمشقي من يوم
دخول المراقبين مراقبين دوليين يرون
الواقع تماما ورفضوا ان يذهبوا الى
الدبابات التي مدينه دوما في اليوم الثاني
من وجودهم وكانت زيارتهم تقتصر على دقائق
ليره اثار القصه انسحبوا ليكمل يستغلون في
النظام قصف او اعتقاله للناشطين مما لاشك
فيه على ارض الواقع القاصي والداني انها
مهمه كوفي عنان في سوق في اتجاه الشعب
السوري قد فشلت
وقد تتوقف على الاسلحه المرخصه كما يدعي
الشريف هذا ولا غير المرخصه صحيفه الازهر
في المدن والبلدات لا تزال ايضا ال ال ال
ال اه الرياض الفقيره والرصاص والصواريخ
هو الذي يحارب المثل في الريف الدمشقي
ولا شك ان هذه المحال وهذه التعديلات كلها
تصب في مصلحه النظام السوري و كله يصب في
المؤامره على هذا الشعب السوري الذي ان
المجلس نعم
وجهات النظر خارج سوريا الان وانتقد اشرت
الى المجتمع الدولي تحديدا انتقل السيد من
نيويورك لعلك سمعت ما قاله السيد محمد
سعيد وهو ناشط معارض من داخل سوريا بان
الزياره المراقبين باتت وبالا على
المواطنين وبات وحتى يخشونها لما تجربه
لهم بعد ذلك من قصف وتدمير وحتى اعتقالات
المواطنين المشاركين في ال في ربما الحديث
الى هؤلاء المراقبين كيف يمكن ربما تجنب
ذلك وهل تعتقد بان زياده عدد المراقبين
ربما قد تعيد التوازن مهمتهم
الامم المتحده قال الدين قلق من وجود
اعمال انتقاميه الدوليه السوريين المدنيين
الذين تحدثوا الى اعضاء ابعد من جديد ولكن
هنا نحن لا نستطيع التحقق من مثل هذه
التقارير
ونفهم ان هناك
الى دمشق القريب العاجل لكننا لا نعلم
حقيقه هل كان هناك تنميه حقيقيه على الارض
طريق الامم المتحده وفريق وفي انا
بعض المصادر الموثوق بها قالت ان هناك
تراجع في معدلات العنف بعد اه وقفت الحوار
الذي دخل حيز التنفيذ الثاني عشر من
الانسان لا تفعل ذلك
مسؤولي الامم المتحده يقولون ان كلا
الطرفين انتهت
الهدنه لكن في عنا اه بان كي مون امين عام
من جانبه يقول ان
الانتهاكات الاكبر تاتي من جانبه الحكومه
لكن كلا الطرفين
وايضا اسيء
قال يوم امس انه ليس فقط انطلاقا
جرعه في المدن لكن هناك اسلحه ثقيله هناك
مدفعيه ميدان
وهي
ليست عاده
لا تشكل اي جزء من سلاح
وكالات ومؤسسات حفظ القانون المدنيه
والشرطه وليست من معدات السلطان المالوفه
في اي مكان وكان الاتفاق ان تكون هناك
قوات شرطه تبقى في المدن بعد وقف اطلاق
النار لحمايه الامن والنظام لكن لا احد
يقبل بوجود مدفعيه ميدان باعتبار الجزء من
هذا العمل لا احد يقبل بوجود مدفعيه
الميدان نتحول السيد شحاده مساله وقت انها
تماما ما قلته وهو منقول عن ممثلي الامم
المتحده بخصوص هذه الاليات وعدم سحبها ايا
كانت الدفوعات التي تتقدم بها الحكومه
السوريه اضافه الى ذلك رفض منح تاشيرات
لبعض المراقبين تحديدا من الدول التي حضرت
مؤتمر اصدقاء سوريا اه اضف الى ذلك اه
ربما اه عدم اه امكانيه تواجد المراقبين
لاكثر من عشره الى خمسه عشر دقيقه فقط مع
المواطنين وبعد ذلك يحدث القصف على هؤلاء
تتم الاعتقالات وكما ذكرنا تعود بنتائج
عكسيه على كل هؤلاء اي اه ال ال عون واين
التعاون الذي تتحدث عنه الحكومه السوريه
مع هؤلاء المراقبين
اه دعيني
السؤال الثاني هو اه مدينه ليسوا هناك في
منطقه اسمه السكانيه بمنظومه واحداث
اكثريه في السابق
هناك على الشارع العام الاستاذ المؤدي الى
كل المحافظات السوريه قوات عسكريه سابقه
ومنتشره على الطرفين على طريق
وليس هناك اهداف
الجماعات البشريه
سابقا
السؤال هناك عسكريه اسمه مطارده
ليست هناك قوات عسكريه المعنيه والجيده
يعني كما اقول انا
العسكريه هي موجوده منذ اكثر من عشرين
ثلاثين في
الناس هناك لكن الان الحديث لانها
المتظاهرين وتصف المواطنين الامنين العزل
معين
سيدتي
من اليوم تعتقد عن المشروعيه
يعني هذا السنويين لا يمكن اه اه
سوريا
المراقبين بالدخول وكوريا لولا انها لم
تريد المراقبين لما وافقت الامم المتحده
ومجلس الامن نحن نريد انجاح عمل المراقب
لكن يجب علينا ان نفهم الشيء اللي على
المراقبين اليورو بعينتين اثنتين
الواحد القوات السوريه نفذت لكن مسؤوليه
الامن الصحه من المسؤوليات الدوليه الدوله
هي المسؤوليه ولا سوريا اليوم وكلها
الشريف البعض المشاهدين يتساءل لماذا
تتواجد اذن عناصر امنيه ترافق هؤلاء
المراقبين ليس هدفها فقط حمايتهم لكن هناك
من يقول بانه يتم بعدها مباشره اصطياد من
تحدث الى هؤلاء المراقبين والانتقام منهم
والحديث للامم المتحده
يقوم الموقع بين سوريا وبين الامم المتحده
سوريا مسؤوليه حمايه هؤلاء المراقبين وهذه
الحمايه مسؤوليه الحكومه السوريه من يقول
ان القوات السوريه فقط بعد ذلك يعني هذا
الكلام يريد الشعب السوري بين بعضهم البعض
وما كلما مسحت سبيل ان انعقد في سوريا
تريد المهم لسوريا وافقت على المهم ومن
اجل العناصر المسلحه بين السوريين يجب ان
يبدا الحوار باسرع وقت
على كل اه
يحدث على الاطلاق الاليات متواجده من ذكره
مثلا عشرين سنه لحمايه المواطنين لحمايتكم
ما اقول
يعني النظام السوري يكثر من بدايه الازمه
السوريين الى ان يعترف وجود مظاهرات الى
هذه الاليات تحدث عنها القطاع العسكري
صحيح هناك قطاع عسكريه بين دمشق بشكل دائم
ولكن اتكلم على الانتشار العسكري احتيال
المدن دخول المدرعات الثقيله الى المدن
قصف الدبابات للمدرب هذا لم يكن موجودا
الا خلال الثوره السوريه لم تشهد لم تخرج
الدبابات من حكوماتها عسكريه ابدا كل اللي
هو كل المبادرات كانت تقول ان يرجع قوات
عسكريه
اذن هناك فكره عسكريه كانت موجوده وهي
الاتصال موجوده ولكن العساكر والمدرعات
الثقيله خارج المدن وهي تقوم بقصف المدن
وليست بحمايتها المدرعه ال ال ال ال
الشوارع بشكل كامل واقول ايضا
حول مساله الانتهاكات من الفرنسيين هم او
الان لم يسمح لهم النظام السوري بالدخول
الى داخل سوريا لكي يتحققوا بانفسهم ثانيا
ان الجيش السوري الحر لايمكنه ان يرى
المدن تقصف والمدنيين تحت الانقاض ثم لا
يتدخل لحمايتهم بحجه ان هناك هدنه ما هذه
الكلمه هدنه يجب ان لا تتوقع الحاله
السوريه بالاصل لم يكن هناك وقف لاطلاق
النار سيكون هناك لا يمكن للجيش السوري
الحر ان يرى على المدرب فيما يذكر ان
توافق هنا تحديدا على ان الجيش السيد محمد
ان اتوقف عند هذه النقطه بان الجيش السوري
الحر لا يمكن ان يقف متفرجا على الاوضاع
عندما يشاهد لان المواطنين يقفون والكلام
لك طبعا سيد محمد السعيد في المقابل في
دمشق حراك شعبي وصفه بالسلبي وغير المسلح
وستكون لنا وقفه وقراءه في هذا الحراك لكن
بعد فاصل قصير ابقوا معنا
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام من جديد وهذه
الحلقه من برنامج ما وراء الخبر نتحول الى
نيويورك والسيد اه لو شبه الصحفي في الامم
المتحده ونسال ان الان عن وجهه نظرك السيد
الح في في الامم المتحده
الاستمرار هذه الاحتجاجات والمظاهرات رغم
كل القمع الذي يتعرض له المواطنون
السوريين وتحديدا مظاهراتهم
اتمنى لو انني استطيع ان اقول واعرف كيف
ستكون مقالات الامور حقيقه لكن حتى الان
لا توجد ايه مؤشرات من وجهه نظرنا نحنا
رجال للسودان في نيويورك الى ان هناك
نهايه قريبه في الافق وهذا ينعكس باعتبار
الوضع انتهى الى مازق
يتبين ذلك من
الطريق المسدود في الامم المتحده وفي
مواقف اصليه وروسيا واعضاء الدول الدائمه
العضويه الخمسه التي تمتلك حق النقد
الفيتو و نسمع اصوات مجلس الامن تقول ان
روسيا لم تسمح باي حال من الاحوال لمجلس
الامن ان يقدم على ايه خطوه في المستقبل
المنظور حول سوريا و هم وافقوا على بعثه
حفظ السلام
وروسيا تريد انجاح
الخطه عمان وهي تفرض ضغوطا على سوريا ونعم
ان سوريا كانت ترفض اصدار دخول بعض
الشخصيات لكن حسب اقوال السيد يوم امس حتى
الان رفضوا ال اعطاء
ثلاث سنوات من بين ثلاثين هذا الرقم ازداد
على ايه حال في هذه النقطه تحديدا
يبدو ان مجلس الامن
دعمه لخطه امام مجلس الامن اذا متمسك اه
مخطط على ويريد لها النجاح اعتبر من
المقاطعه فيما تبقى من وقت نود ان نتحول
الى ضيفنا شريف حاده
سؤالا اه عذرا الجواب مباشرا على السؤال
كيف يمكن تفسير استمرار الاحتجاجات السنيه
خاصه في دمشق مع كل العام القمع الذي
يتعرض لها المواطنون
نعم
الا ان تكون مع التظاهر في كل دول العالم
واعتقد ان الحكومه الصينيه توافق على
عندما زاره تريد
ضمن المجال والقوانين الا في سوريا لكن اه
يعني انتم تقولون هذه المظاهرات في وزارات
بخير للمراه ان هذه التظاهرات بالملايين
لا علينا
القمع الممارس جدا المواطنين واه التقييد
على هذه المظاهرات والاعتقالات لان الناس
اقتنعت بان هذا النظام يجب ان يبقى
تراجعت وزارات دكتور الاجتماع العالم
اللقاء بين
نظريه المؤامره اذن
نعم اعتذر لضيق الوقت حول اه في سؤال اخر
للسيد محمد سعيد اذن المظاهرات تراجعت
السوريون اقتنعوا بان هناك مؤامره كبيره
ضدهم وبالتالي اه هم لم يعودوا يخرجوا
للتظاهر كيف يمكن كرد على ذلك
هذا مجرد كلام وخيارات الخرافات
ان التظاهرات في زياده وعددها كبير اليوم
تخلط وجه مراقبين الى اللي كان هناك مائه
الف متظاهر اكبر مظاهره في سوريا الاطلاق
رجعت التظاهرات اللي غالب المدن السوريه
بكثافه على واقول ان المظاهرات لازم لا
تزال السلميه لا يعني لا تقول الحريه
موجود ولكن الجيش الحر هو المنشق الذي
يدافع عن المدنيين ثانيه نقول انه اذا كان
من كما تفضلت في نيويورك اذا كان ال ال اه
الكلام ومحمد حول انه ليس هناك حل يلوح
بالافق وانه
متمسكون
ومن هذا الكلام هذا الكلام محمد كيف ليس
محل او او لا يرون يعني ال التزام ال ال
النظام السوري بالمبادره يكتفوا بالتنديد
وال وال مطالبه بوقف اطلاق النار هذا ليس
كافيا هذا ليس كافيا لاطلاق النظام السوري
كما تسمعيني يردد ال السنيه المراه مؤامره
من بدايه الثوره السوريه ل لان والشعب
السوري وينزف يقتل من الذي قتل عشرات
الالاف من السوريين
التي لم ت لا توجد الا في خيالات
النظام السوري او غيره يجب على الامم
المتحده اذا كانت فعلا هي الامم المتحده
وقاده للعالم ان ان يتحركوا بجديه لانقاذ
الشعب السوري من القتل المستمر عليهم كل
يوم كل يوم كل هذه المظاهرات والمظاهرات
هدفها اسقاط النظام السوري هذا يعني ب ب
اه هذه هي مطالب الشعب السوري وال مظاهره
وهذا على السيد شريف حاضرا ايضا الذي قال
بانه لا هدف في هذه المظاهره اشكرك جزيل
الشكر محمد السعيد اه عضو مجلس الثوره
السوريه كنت معنا من دوما بريف دمشق عبر
سكايب كما اشكر ضيفنا
الصحفي في الامم المتحده كان معنا من
نيويورك ونشكر ضيفنا الاعلامي الشريف
الحادث الذي كان معنا من دمشق بهذا
مشاهدينا الكرام تنتهي هذه الحلقه من
برنامج ما وراء الخبر نلتقي باذن الله في
قراءه جديده فيما وراء خبر جديد السلام
عليكم
ام